this talk is the latest in what's
becoming a series of taking a Rob Pike
proverb and kind of building a whole
idea around it so to kind of set the
scene for this if we if I look in the
room and I ask you what is the most
important criteria of go someone is
going to yell out to me readability the
thing is that I disagree so in this talk
I'm gonna talk about the difference
between readability and clarity and I'll
show you what I mean by clarity we're
going to apply to some go code and I'm
gonna end by arguing that go programmers
should strive for clarity
not just readability in the programs
that we write so before I pick apart the
difference between readability and
clarity we need to ask the question why
would I read your code now when I say I
I don't mean me I actually mean you and
when I say your code well it also mean
you but in the third person so what I'm
really saying is why would you read
another person's code Oh a man who stood
on this stage yes said last year said
this software engineering is what
happens to programming and you add time
and other programmers so the answer of
why would I read your code is because we
have to work together maybe we don't
work in the same office we don't even
live in the same city maybe we don't
even work for the same company but we do
have to collaborate on a piece of
software and if we don't collect if not
at least clever on the same software we
prorate least consume it as a dependency
so I think this is the essence of what
Russ is saying software engineering is
the collaboration of software engineers
over time I have to read your code you
have to read my code so that I can
maintain it so that you can understand
it and in short so that any programmer
can change it
now just to be clear I don't mean to
dismiss the work of like the lone
programmer working in a small company
with no one to work with or mentor from
I mean God knows I've been in that
position throughout throughout my career
but the fact remains the Russ is making
a distinction between software
programming and software engineering the
former programming is a program that you
write for yourself the ladder is a
project a service a product that many
people will contribute to over a long
amount of time and engineers will come
and grow teams will grow in size and
shrink requirements are going to change
features going to be added and bugs are
going to be fixed this is just the
nature of what we do in software
engineering
now Peter Siebel suggests that source
code isn't actually read it's not
literature instead we decode it I mean
the name is right there encode and
decode so the source code is some kind
of intermediary form it's it's somewhere
between what's in our brains and what
the command what the computer wants
source code is this intermediary form
and in my experience the most common
complaint when people are faced with a
fine codebase they're told they have to
maintain some code or they're brought in
on a bug from and something another team
wrote and they the most common thing
they'll say is are this code is
unreadable does anyone agree with me
have you ever if you ever said these
words when being asked to look at
somebody else's code I got huh oh it's
unreadable but readability is a
subjective concept readability is things
like nitpicking about line lengths and
variable names readability is having a
holy war about brace positions
readability is this hand-to-hand combat
of style guides and code review
guidelines that regulate insignificant
things like whitespace now on the other
hand clarity is the property of code on
the page clear code is independent of
low-level details like function names
and indentation because clear code is
concerned with what the code is doing
it's not interested in how it's written
down when I say a foreign code base is
unreadable
what I think I really mean is that I
don't understand it so I can't read it
as I can't understand it
and so through a few case studies I want
to explore this idea with the difference
between clear code and clothed that is
simply readable now Inco we have many
ways to declare variables some would
argue we have too many for a language of
the very Spartan syntax which need to
have a lot of different ways to say the
same thing
I'm sure there's there's even more I'm
not even thinking about per function
parameters return values there it'll
this goes on how can we make it clear to
the reader what is the purpose of each
declaration the answer comes down to the
intent because are we declaring a
variable which is going to be assigned
later
or are we declaring it and specifically
initializing it that's its purpose so
here's the suggestion that I want to try
and defend when you declare a variable
that will be explicitly initialized
later use var the var acts as a clue to
say that we have deliberately chosen not
to initialize this we have deliberately
chosen that we're going to let that let
it be the zero value to the reader it's
clear that the responsibility for
actually assigning that very lives
somewhere else and hopefully not too far
from where its declared so the opposite
is when declaring and initializing at
the same time that's to say we're not
letting things fall through to the the
zero value use the short use the short
declaration form and again this makes it
clear to the reader that the variable on
the left-hand side is being explicitly
initialized from the expression on the
right let's expand on these suggestions
and do a little exercise so we have
three three examples in the first form
where deliberate these are the zero
values for all of these different types
let's go back so to try and show by
proof by refutation
let's explicitly initialize them like
these are the implicit values let's
explicitly initialize them
this is kind of pointless because the
compiler can infer from the type on the
right hand side the type on the left so
for example saying players int equals
zero he's kind of pointless because well
zero isn't it in that case and now now
we kind of see that this is even sillier
that we're explicitly declaring a value
and saying you're zero the zero value
the the one that you get for free so it
makes I kind of think it makes it clear
that rather than explicitly initializing
something to at zero value use the use
the this form to say this is the zero
value we've explicitly chosen not to
initialize this what about the second
statement we're explicitly initializing
it to nil which is the zero value for a
slice now we can't elide the type in
this case because in this context nil
doesn't really have a type so we have a
choice to make are we actually saying
this is the zero fifo for a slice a nil
an uninitialized slice or do we want to
say that this is a slice with no
elements and they're different like one
is nil the other is initialized slice
that contains no elements now if we
wanted the latter we should make it
explicit that we're making this choice
well for whatever reason we want a slice
with no elements so we should use the
short declaration form now it's kind of
unclear why you'd want to do this it's
kind of a smell that you would have some
code that can tell the difference
between a nil slice and a slice with no
elements but if you need to if you need
to if this wish actually your intent you
should make it clear using this form so
that brings us to the third declaration
we're both explicitly initializing a
variable and introducing the uncommon
use of new
we apply our short declaration rule then
it becomes this which makes it clear
that were explicitly initializing thing
to be a pointer to a new thing but it
still leaves us with this unusual use of
new now we could address that using the
short declaration form so this sorry the
compact Alysha literal initializer and
this is the thing that kind of upsets
programmers when they find that there's
two ways of doing things you every say
new or you take the address of a compact
literal but more importantly it means
that we're explicitly initializing thing
to be at zero value like we've not given
any fields there we've not chosen any
any fields about its properties
we're just saying give me the new
default thing so instead we should
recognize that we are just saying just
give me the new default thing we don't
want to initialize it and instead what
we want to do is take the dress of it
and pass that down to unmarshal
so with any rule there are always
exceptions for example if we applied the
rules that I just talked about before we
have two two variables min and Max which
obviously closely related like the
minimum a maximum there's something to
do with a range but they're declared in
different in different forms so by
breaking this rule a little bit you can
see it's much clearer you can see that
they're now related min and Max are now
related even though we're explicitly
initializing minimum to a value which is
its default and we do this because when
something is complicated it should look
complicated this is this is coming back
to clarity like when you see the tricky
things they should stand out in this
example length is being used with a
library which requires a specific type
like it's not okay for it to just be an
int it has to be a 32-bit unsigned
integer but how obvious is that
requirement to the reader
you might come along and say well why
are we converting 82 at UN 32 I can just
remove that cast that's fine but that's
important to the program it's important
to the readability you may think the
type system will catch you but if you
pass this through something that uses
reflect to look at the type you may not
you may not actually see a compile error
it may just kind of subtly break the
program so instead
again we bend the we bend the rule and
we explicitly give length to type we
don't let it flow from the right hand
side of the expression we give it a type
and say this is this is the type that we
need and it looks unusual because it's
uncommon it's it's it's it's rare to
have to do this so where it is necessary
it should be obvious I may be
misinterpreting this quote that Brian
Kernighan says if something is unusual
unusual is happening you should leave
evidence to the reader and so that's
what we're doing here adopting a
consistent declaration style so that
it's clear when something is is unusual
it looks unusual and it's a clue to the
reader just to pay extra attention the
next case study I want to talk about how
we can use interfaces to describe the
behavior that we expect from function
from parameters and return values rather
than being caught up in nearly greedy of
the implementation let's say I've been
given a task to implement a way of
saving this big document structure it
doesn't really matter what it does but
we want to save it out to disk that was
the requirement that was the what it
said on the ticket so we could come up
with something like this and there are a
few problems don't want to guess what
some of the problems are with this I
mean the functionality works but the
file so that not only is that going to
make it kind of inflexible like we can't
write to a network connection we can't
not it can we not write to a network
connection but we can't even write it
out to like an in-memory buffer which
means if you want to write a test for
this you're going to have to put that
you're gonna have to create a temporary
file pass it to that close the file read
the file back in to check the output
that's that's annoying that's going to
risk that you kind of reuse the same
temporary file you can't run your tests
in parallel whole whole slew of problems
they'll saw another problem that file
can do a lot of things if you have a
file a file an OS file you can ask it
for a directory you can say change its
permissions you can say I owe you a
symlink you can do a whole bunch of
things which are not related to what SAV
wants to do so what would be really
useful is if we could document in the
signature not just in like in a comment
but in the signature the operations that
SAV intends to do now being here in goal
and of course we're going to use an
interface with this
so using a rewrite closer we apply the
interface segregation principle and
we've redefined save in terms of the
behaviors it needs rather the
implementation that it's been passed
this makes save both broader in its
application now you can save to anything
that reads and writes and closes but it
also makes it more specific to the
reader it's clear that save reads and
writes and closes it can't do anything
else because that's the only behaviour
that's been provided with now that's
great like we took we looked at the
behaviors that file exposed and we kind
of found a matching interface but we've
actually introduced some some ambiguity
there I mean for example if save is
going to write out the file it's
unlikely if this code is well well
factored that it's going to read it back
in to verify it like that should be the
behavior of another part of the program
so save doesn't actually need the
behavior of the ability to read just to
write so we can shrink the interface we
can make it smaller which gives us more
flexibility now now more things probably
satisfy that interface and also again
makes it clearer but again we have we
have this question of okay so it can
write to save can write to the thing and
it can close the thing and that leaves
the question of well when is it going to
close them is it always going to like
after save it's just going to close the
thing unconditionally maybe it only
closes if the if the operation works
otherwise it leaves it open there's no
way to really express that in a type
system you're you're back to putting a
big comment on that
for example if we passed a network
connection into that and that was our
like HTTP connection that we're writing
a bunch of theorizing a bunch of
documents the first call to save is
going to close the string on us and we
can't continue to write data so we could
do something like this we could make a
little type and interpose it and this
thing is both a writer and a closer
because it embeds a writer and has a
closed method but the close method just
throws just doesn't close there's no up
closer but this is a violation of the
Liskov substitution principle this thing
fits through the interface we have but
it has different behavior it's a closer
that doesn't close things so the better
solution is to redefine save and remove
remove the ability to close and give
make that the behavior of something else
something higher up and so now save only
gets a writer and it can only write data
this makes it really general we can now
pass anything like a bytes buffer will
work great here it also makes it more
specific it is crystal clear to the
reader that all save does is write
things because that's the only behavior
it can observe and something as I was
working in this example occurred to me
that well now we've factored this the
signature down to this it's got the
wrong name like it saves but the only
thing that actually does is right so
maybe maybe it should have a better name
maybe it should just be called right to
it I don't list that in the opening I
said that naming is this kind of kind of
small beer but like once you've factored
this down and removed the extraneous
noise it's clear that this this is
probably a better name for that function
so in Ko traditionally we write code in
a style that favors guard causes and
preconditions this encouraged the
successful path of the code to start at
the top and work its way down the code
the opposite of course is when the
successful path is inside the block and
it kind of is nested in and in and in
and in if you start any language not
going to name any names but it has a
kind of strong analogy to coffee that
that's the that's the predominant style
the successful case goes inside these
nested these nested blocks now this rule
of starting at the top and working your
way down Matt right calls line-of-sight
coding because the success path the code
that you're writing is always in your
line of sight it's in no danger of
sliding off to the right-hand side and
out of view of your screen so by keeping
conditional block short and for
exceptional conditions rather than the
expected condition we avoid this nesting
and we've also avoid potential hazards a
variable shadowing because the success
flow always flows down the page you know
when you get to line 50 in the function
that a set of preconditions have have
been built up if you can get to here
then this is true and this is true and
this is true and this is true rather
than having to match braces and like
hope that your your editor can do the
internet indentation correctly the
canonical example this is our beloved
error check idiom if error not nil then
return to the caller otherwise continue
on with the function and the thing is
that we can actually generalize this if
condition so if that condition is true
then do some continued cleanup behavior
and return to the caller if the
condition is false continue on and this
holds true for error checks it holds
true for type assertions it holds true
for map lookups the to value map lookup
it looks hot holds true for to value
versions of can receive and things like
that
go programmers know when they see code
in this form this is a guard clause we
know it instinctually this is this adds
to the this adds to the clarity so you
don't even need to know what the
condition is like you just need to know
if something fails we're going to clean
up and return otherwise we're going to
keep going on and it's familiarity aids
you building understanding the code
I haven't actually finished this book
but it's full of wonderful wonderful
kind of observations like this that
structured programming the Dijkstra
structured programming of sequence
selection iteration and recursion
actually submerges the structure you
don't spend time worrying about the
structure of different controls things
you're it emphasizes the behavior I said
another way what is the code trying to
do not how is it trying to do it so
let's keep exploring this idea we have a
comparison function and it's it's it's
written in the previous style but unlike
the previous version we we can't just
look at the guard clause and say oh
that's a guard cause okay if that if
that fails then they return it's
actually more complicated so if a is
less than B return minus one if a is
more than B return positive one and if
neither of those cases so by inference a
and B are the same we return zero now
the problem with comp is the way that
it's written
unlike the guard cost someone who's
maintaining this function has to read
all of it they have to understand what
are the what are the conditions that let
us fall through to zero and the only way
to know those is to explore all the
previous ones
and that doesn't look so bad I mean it's
this is an example that fits on a slide
but for the work that we're paid to do
our code is rarely slide sized and the
conditions and the bodies of the work is
rarely one-line they're more complicated
so let's address the problem of making
it clear under what conditions zero is
returned now although this code is not
what anybody would argue is readable I
mean the long chains of if-else are
explicitly discouraged it's now
absolutely clear that the reader to the
reader that zero is only returned if
neither of the other two comparisons are
changed and how can I make this
assertion because if we did something
like this it doesn't compile
so as the reader I know that I only need
to care about I only need to care about
the block that I'm working in because
all of the others must end in what we
say the speck is a terminating statement
so that's clear to the reader this isn't
actually a series of conditions it's an
example of selection we're selecting one
of three return values based on the
input but this code is really hard to
read like it took four slides to go
through it and work and work through it
and it's only seven lines long this is
because each of the conditions is
phrased slightly differently the first
one is just a normal if the second one
is the uncommon else--if and the third
one doesn't have a condition at all so
given that this is selection we have a
much better tool for this and that is of
course switch now it's clear to us as
the reader that this is a selection
we're selecting between one or three
cases the conditions under which we are
select are nicely laid out there and we
know that we don't need to worry about
reading anything in the body of the
cases that we don't select there is
unfortunately the case of fail through a
fall through which totally wrecks this
analysis so this is why you there's a
general disapproval of fail fall through
so I opened this talk with a discussion
of readability versus clarity and I also
hinted that perhaps there are some other
principles of well written go code so it
seems fitting to close with a little
discussion of those last year Brian
Cantrell gave this wonderful
presentation not about programming
language is bad about operating systems
and the kind of guiding principles or
core values that and different operating
system projects have his is his point
was twofold one that different projects
have different sets of core values it's
not that they disregard other values
it's just when you have to make a choice
you have to choose one over the other so
what are the the core set of principles
for go code hopefully if you're going to
say readability hopefully today I've
given you an alternative
Cody's going to be read many many more
times than it's written single posts
single piece of code over its lifetime
like to say it's be read a hundreds of
thousands of times is completely
believable if you think about the code
base that you work on every day you
think about how how many people have
just perused the go standard library
just for just for support is easily
provable that code is read thousands of
times more than it is written so clarity
is important to all software not just go
programs because all programs are
written by humans to be read by other
humans the fact that the software is
consumed by a machine is just a
secondary concern now if you're writing
a program for yourself that only has to
run once or you're the only ever person
who'll see it then just do whatever
works for you but if that's a piece of
software that more than one person will
contribute to or it's going to be used
over long enough time that the
requirements will change or the program
will live for long enough that the
environment in which it runs in changes
then your core goal must be for that
program to be maintainable and the first
step to writing maintainable code is
making sure that the intent of the code
is clear the next principle um is
simplicity I mean some may argue that
that is the most important principle in
a programming language I mean perhaps
it's the most important principle
everywhere it's the most important
principle . so why should we strive for
simplicity why is important the go
programs be simple we've all been in the
situation we say I can't understand that
code we've all worked on programs where
you're too scared to make a change
because you were worried that it would
break another area of the code that you
didn't understand you'd you'd carved out
a little a little island of
understanding of just this part but you
were terrified of changing it because
what if it broke something way over
there and the other part of the code
that you didn't understand
and the thing is if you don't understand
how it broke how will you know how to
fix it and this is fundamentally
complexity complexity turns reliable
software into unreliable software
complexity is what kills software
projects now we have clarity and
simplicity as interlocking forces that
give us the language that we've come
here to celebrate today so whatever
programs we write we should be able to
agree that they are clear and they're
simple and then make us as go
programmers more productive which is a
good segue into the last principle now
developer productivity is a kind of
again a very wide-ranging and subjective
term but I think it boils down to this
how much time do you spend getting
useful work done versus how much time do
you spend waiting on your tools or
hopelessly lost
go programmers should feel that they can
get a lot done and that the joke goes
that go was designed while waiting for a
C++ program to compile it's perhaps a
little bit of a stretch but this is this
is from Rob Rob spikey Rob's post in
2012 I start another compilation and in
that time I had to turn at the time to
turn around to robert and eek out the
design of a new language
so while compilation speed is always a
battleground it's fair to say that
compilations that take minutes in other
languages take seconds for us and this
helps NGO developers feel productive as
feels as productive as their
counterparts working dynamic languages
but we gained the we gained the men at
maintenance benefits of a statically
typed language
more fundamental to the question of
developer productivity go programmers
realize that code is read and so they
place the act of reading code over the
act of writing it that's why we don't
optimize for clever one-liners we even
go so far as to enforce by tooling that
all go code is formatted in a specific
style this removes that friction of the
dialect that you see when moving between
different code bases because one pass
through go format which your editor has
probably already done before you even
saw the saw the file and it's already in
the traditional format go programmers
don't spend days debugging inscrutable
compile errors we don't waste days on
complicated build scripts except for
basil I have no idea why people use that
thing or deploying code to production
just SCP and you're done and most
importantly they don't spend their time
trying to understand what their
co-workers wrote to say that go is a
language designed to be productive is
understanding that it's it's built for
software design in the large it's built
for industrial applications
now something don't know about each of
you although I've I've met very few of
you is that eventually every one of you
will leave your current employer perhaps
you'll move on to a new role perhaps you
get a promotion
perhaps you move to a new city or you
follow your partner overseas I'm sure
that's a common story for people in the
room for whatever reason because of this
fact we must consider secession of
maintaining ship of the programs we
write so if we strive to write programs
which are clear programs which is simple
and a focus on the productivity of those
working around us then we set all the go
programs that we've brought into this
world in good stead
because the alternative is if we don't
we move from job to job and we leave
behind programs which can't be
maintained we leave behind programs that
can't be changed programs that are too
hard to onboard new developers and
programs that season developers realizes
kind of career diversions they don't
want to be stuck using that older editor
at a date stuff if software cannot be
maintained then it will be rewritten
and unfortunately that could be the last
time that your company will invest in go
so on that bombshell I'm gonna leave you
to hopefully right clear a code for
those that come after you thank you very
much please enjoy go for Khan Singapore
[Applause]